kandidatenkür und wahlprogramm auf ihrem
parteitag ruft die spd zur aufholjagd
vor der bundestagswahl auf lockerungen
bei sonnenschein geimpfte und genesene
genießen ab heute bundesweit mehr
freiheiten und erinnern an sophie scholl
die widerstandskämpferin der weißen rose
hätte heute ihren 100 geburtstag
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend schön dass
sie dabei sind wie auch die zähne für
den sport hallo guten ab die spd muss
sich etwas einfallen lassen wenn sie bis
zur bundestagswahl in vier monaten
wähler zurückgewinnen will
derzeit liegt sie in umfragen bei 15
prozent
der virtuelle parteitag heute sollte ein
signal zum aufholen setzen mit neuem
programm und 96 prozent zustimmung für
olaf scholz als kanzlerkandidat andreas
huppert und lars boom sagt berichten
eigentlich sind viele genossen
unzufrieden mit den derzeitigen
umfragewerten ihrer partei gemessen
daran sind die 96,2 prozent für olaf
scholz ein durchaus erstaunliches
ergebnis
ich bedanke mich bei allen für dieses
großartige ergebnis
das ist nicht selbstverständlich und es
ist aber trotzdem die basis für den
erfolg den wir erreichen wollen
basis für scholz rede ist das neue
wahlprogramm das ist geprägt von den
begriffen respekt und würde bei der
arbeit in der gesellschaft im sozialen
miteinander
der spd-kanzlerkandidat fordert mehr
gesetzliche und finanzielle
gerechtigkeit jede arbeit hat ihre würde
jede arbeit verdient respekt genau dafür
steht der mindestlohn ein gesetzlicher
mindestlohn von mindestens zwölf euro
pro stunde er ist überfällig
in ihrem wahlprogramm versprechen die
sozialdemokraten bezahlbaren wohnraum
für alle und schärfen die klimaziele
nach deutschland solle bereits 2045
klimaneutral sein
dazu braucht es einen sozialdemokraten
im kanzleramt
ich kann meine erfahrung meine kraft und
meine ideen einbringen als
regierungschef der stadt hamburg als
minister als vizekanzler
als überzeugter europäer mit ihrem
wahlprogramm wollen sich die
sozialdemokraten sowohl von der union
als auch von den grünen absetzen
dafür will olaf scholz nicht nur links
sondern eben auch in der politischen
mitte punkten zur corona lage da wächst
die hoffnung auf lockerungen
mittlerweile hat die hälfte der
bundesländer eine 7 tage incidents von
unter
100 vollständig geimpfte und genesene
sind seit mitternacht schon von kontakt-
und ausgangs beschränkungen befreit
zudem brauchen sie für einkäufe oder
friseurbesuche keinen test mehr es
reicht der impfausweis oder ein maximal
sechs monate alter pcr test als beleg
für eine überstandene infektion an
seinem stand
es ist ein sonntag zum auftanken sonne
wärme leichtigkeit wieder möglich ist
ein bisschen von dem was so lange
unmöglich war zumindest an manchen orten
im land wie hier
timmendorfer strand eine von mehreren
modellregionen in schleswig holstein
es ist wirklich ein richtig tiefes
durchatmen
dieser strand das meer gibt so viel
kraft kraft kosten die vielen
unterschiedlichen regeln das ist
boltenhagen mecklenburg vorpommern hier
hat alles zu kommen dürfen nur menschen
mit vollen impfschutz und genesene und
auch nur als tagestouristen das zu
kontrollieren fast unmöglich ist zu
vermitteln mindestens schwierig die
leute verstehen es nicht mehr also sie
verstehen nicht dass hier zum beispiel
menschen die ihr gift sind kommen dürfen
aber deren kinder zum beispiel nicht und
sie sagen sie haben auf der einen seite
sorge dass sie sich anstecken können auf
der anderen seite gibt es große
existenzielle nöte und in diesem
spannungsfeld ist der druck momentan
täglich spürbar
ein spannungsfeld das größer wird folge
impfte viele genesene haben seit heute
viel mehr freiheit vor
gerechtigkeitsproblem in warnt der
deutsche ethikrat und macht die
ungeimpften nicht zu vergessen und man
kann auch darüber reden ob man etwa sehr
viel schneller an universitäten impft
die man das dann auch in betrieben tut
etwa über kinderärztin kinderärzte auch
junge eltern im jahr auch diese weise
auch ihre kinder schützen
fest steht miteinander und verständnis
bleiben gefragt auch an diesem sonntag
zum auftanken und jetzt noch der blick
auf die aktuellen zahlen bundesweit
meldet das rk ii 12 1656 neuinfektionen
binnen 24 stunden das sind 3634 weniger
als am vergangenen sonntag
107 und 2
todesfälle kamen hinzu die bundesweite
sieben tage incident sinkt auf 118,6
seit die nato ihren rückzug aus
afghanistan beschlossen hat befürchten
experten noch mehr gewalt in dem land
jetzt traf ein verheerender anschlag vor
allem kinder nach der detonation vor
einer schule ist die zahl der opfer auf
mehr als 50 gestiegen darunter viele
schülerinnen drei sprengsätze
explodierten
als die kinder gestern die mädchenschule
in kabul verließen
wer für den anschlag verantwortlich ist
ist unklar
mit einer großen militärparade hat
russland heute den sowjetischen sieg
über nazi-deutschland vor 76 jahren
gefeiert in moskau marschierten tausende
soldaten über den roten platz militärs
präsentierten panzer raketen und
kampfflugzeuge
gedacht wird an diesem tag auch der etwa
27 millionen kriegstoten des landes das
liegt an meinem tod wenn ich durch unser
handeln tausende menschen aufgerüttelt
werden
das sagte sophie scholl einen tag vor
ihrer hinrichtung
sie rief zum widerstand gegen das
nazi-regime auf in flugblättern die sie
zusammen mit weiteren studierenden der
weißen rose erstellte und verteilte
dafür haben die nazis die 21-jährige
enthauptet heute wäre sie 100 geworden
anlass an ihren unglaublichen mut zu
erinnern brigitte sei im namen der
ganzen deutschen jugend
fordern wir vor dem start adolf hitlers
die persönliche freiheit zurück bei
einer demo in münchen spüren 100 junge
menschen heute einer frau nach die
bereit war in den tod zu gehen für ihre
überzeugungen sophie scholl bringt den
widerstand im februar 43 an der münchner
uni zum fliegen
die texte der weißen rose prangern den
tödlichen wahnsinn der nazis an
das war genau der tag an dem goebbels in
berlin die berüchtigte rede hielt mit
der frage wollt ihr den totalen krieg
und diese flugblätter sagt nein nein zum
krieg zur diktatur zu den verbrechen des
regimes
tausende flugblätter hatte die weiße
rose bereits verteilt diesmal erwischten
sie sophie und ihren bruder hans und
verurteilen sie zum tode
als jugendliche war sophie noch
begeistert in hitlers bund deutscher
mädel aktiv gewesen
nun war sie widerstandskämpferin in
einem system das allein schon die
forderung nach freiheit als hochverrat
wertete das war die zeit einer
mörderischen diktatur wenn heute jemand
für sich meinungsfreiheit der anspruch
dann kann ich nur sagen die demokratie
gewährt sehen und diese zeiten nicht
auseinanderzuhalten schmälert auch nicht
nur die erinnerung an die weiße rose an
sophie scholl sondern schmälert auf der
tat nur vier tage nach ihrer tat wurden
sophie und hans scholl hingerichtet ihr
mut inspiriert die menschen bis heute
300 millionen dollar für den kampf gegen
korona so viel hat ein benefiz-konzert
gebracht die in kalifornien
aufgezeichnete show mit pop stars wie
jennifer lopez wurde nun im us tv
ausgestrahlt
[Musik]
mit dabei prinz harry und per video
papst franziskus sowie das us präsident
sie forderten eine solidarische
verteilung der korona impfstoffe in
aller welt publikum durfte übrigens auch
dabei seien vor allem das pflegepersonal
auch schön jetzt dem sport motorsport
dritter sieg im vierten rennen für
formel 1 weltmeister lewis hamilton im
mercedes vor red-bull-pilot max
verdoppeln
hamilton baut die wm-führung weiter aus
beim konkreten barcelona blieben die
deutschen fahrer sebastian vettel und
mit schumacher ohne punkte jubel in der
kommando box die mercedes zwei stopp
strategie ist voll aufgegangen sechs
runden vor schluss überholte lewis
hamilton seinen härtesten wm-rivalen max
verstappen von red bull dessen reifen
hatten nach nur einem stopp zu stark
abgebaut so vergrößert lewis hamilton
seine gesamtführung in der wm wertung ab
14 punkte
die deutschen piloten fahren auf ihren
startpositionen
sebastian vettel m s martin auf 13 mit
schumacher auf 18 im harz bei der
kanu-wm in ivrea in italien hat sie der
ist asiat ist die bronzemedaille
gewonnen
der olympia zweite von 2000 12 fuhr ein
fehlerfreies rennen und hat sich damit
im kanuslalom für die spiele in tokio
qualifiziert
der sieg ging an den franzosen der nidda
roche an zwei von drei sonntagsspielen
in der fußball-bundesliga sind beendet
am 32
spieltag unterliegt der abstiegsbedrohte
erst fc köln dem sc freiburg mit 1 zu 4
frankfurt und mainz trennen sich eins zu
eins das spitzenspiel der
frauenfußball-bundesliga zwischen
meister wolfsburg und tabellenführer
bayern münchen endet 1 1 damit spricht
vieles für den titelgewinn der
bäuerinnen erschöpfung nach dem kraftakt
in wolfsburg zwei punkte und 20 tore
vorsprung für bayern zwei spieltage vor
schluss münchen athletisch und
kämpferisch stark geht in einer
ausgeglichenen begegnung nach 33 minuten
durch sidney lohmann in führung
insgesamt hat der tabellenführer sogar
mehr torchancen doch titelverteidiger
wolfsburg gelingt in der 81 minute der
ausgleich durch eva prior eins zu eins
feiern auf kurs zum vierten titel nach
1976 2015 und 2016
das war es vom sport an diesem sonntag
war dann sehr gerne
das wetter ist morgen zweigeteilt im
osten viel sonne sonst wechselnd bewölkt
und zunächst nur vereinzelt schauer am
nachmittag im südwesten kräftiger regen
im norden einzelne gewitter höchstwerte
17 bis 30 grad
das war es von uns um 21 uhr 45 begrüßt
sie marietta slomka im heute-journal
hier übernimmt morgen petra gerster wir
wünschen ihnen noch einen schönen
sonntagabend und empfehlen jetzt berlin
direkt